hi my name is Ryan Haggerty and I am the
director of photography for the
feature-length narrative film blood on
the leaves and I'm here to talk to you a
little bit about the camera that we
ended up choosing for this particular
production and some of the reasons why
we ended up making the decision to go
with the camera that we did so go ahead
and show you we ended up shooting with
the Panasonic gh4 which came out I think
around 2014 and the big to-do about this
camera initially was the fact that it
shot 4k footage not a huge motivating
factor for our production you know a lot
of movies are still projected in 2k and
blu-ray for that matter is you know a
lot of blu-rays still done in 2k or
1080p and it looks fantastic you know
you can't really tell the difference
between that and 4k but some of the the
bigger reasons I suppose why we picked
this camera had to do with the price the
dynamic range the battery life in the
file size so price an independent
filmmaking is kind of King you know
we're all working with very tight
budgets and just to give you an idea
with this particular production we were
shooting on a 13 day schedule so you
know the primary cast and crew were
there for around two weeks and we were
shooting you know every day there was
always something going on and hence the
the title blood on the leaves we were
shooting in the woods a lot so you can
imagine we didn't have a lot of place to
plug in outlet you know to outlets for
power and things like that so that
certainly helps make a lot of decisions
for you but with the gh4 actually it
purchased this camera February 2015 and
was using it on productions that I was
doing for clients I already owned it so
that helped out a lot with the price I
was also looking at potentially renting
a sony a7s or Blackmagic Design also has
their pocket Cinema Camera and in two
those two cameras actually do a couple
things really well the Blackmagic pocket
camera has a really wide dynamic range
and it also has a relatively less
compressed file format which means when
you get it into post-production you want
to do color correction and grading you
have a lot of leeway with that
particular camera the sony on the other
hand it has a a picture profile called s
log2 which records pretty flat footage
for the most part you know low contrast
not a lot of saturation the colors which
also lends itself to post-production so
you can capture that highlight in that
shadow detail and apply the look that
you want at that point
versus having it baked in and camera the
gh4 on the other hand it has a couple
different profiles in it such as scene
II D which do tend to look a little bit
more cinematic hence the the cine
partisan II D there but they're not as
flat as a log profile but Panasonic was
actually rumored in 2015 to be releasing
v log for this camera and I believe it
was actually announced maybe in spring
of 2015 they were actually gonna roll it
out and luckily for us we filmed in
October it came out in September so
actually got that enabled on this camera
was able to test it out and see how it
looked on the computer and you know
apply some nuts to it and things like
that and was pretty happy with the
flexibility of V log so you know we had
the log profile we have a camera that
can shoot in 4k which you can crop into
which is a nice perk but the other
things that I mentioned the battery life
and the file size while not the most
exciting things to talk about certainly
affect the price for instance on the
Blackmagic camera while it shoots on an
SD card
much like the gh4 does the file sizes
themselves are a lot larger
so the gh4 when you're shooting in the
cinematic 4k mode this is a little 64
gig SD card you can get about an hour
and 25 minutes
the footage onto one card whereas the
Blackmagic pocket camera shoots and
different flavours of footage I know you
can shoot pro res DNxHD and I believe
there's some kind of compressed RAW
format you can shoot on that but you're
going to get generally a lot less
footage on the same size memory card
which when you're in the middle of the
woods is kind of a big deal because you
don't want to have to carry a million
memory cards you're gonna lose and it
also saves your own money but then on
the post-production side of things at
the end of the day when you're logging
all that footage it's gonna take you
time which when you're really tired at
the end of the day getting that kind of
stuff done accurately is kind of a
important part of it but also you don't
have to buy as many hard drives to be
able to backup your footage so file size
was a big deal and also being out in the
woods as I mentioned earlier we didn't
have anywhere to really plug in power
that was convenient so you know the gh4
just takes these little fairly
inexpensive batteries and one charge
battery depending on how you use the
camera could last you anywhere from two
to four hours so you know the battery
life was a really big deal for for our
production which was one of the reasons
in addition to price that we didn't
really go after that Blackmagic camera
or the sony camera if you have a lot of
batteries at your disposal certainly
those cameras might better suit your
needs
so mention a lot of the good things
about this as far as perhaps its
weaknesses or things that it doesn't do
really well it is a crop sensor camera
so it doesn't gather light as well as
say an aps-c or 35 millimeter motion
picture camera or even a full-frame
camera like the sony a7s does and we did
have some nighttime scenes so in order
to compensate for that low-light I
actually added this meta bone speed
booster which is a both a lens adapter
and it also has glass elements in it
that allow you to it gathers essentially
an extra stop of light onto the image
sensor and makes it you know gather
light more efficiently it also in
the apparent field of view of the lens
that you put on it to make it actually
wider so and both of those things did
help us in various ways of the nighttime
scene obviously having more light was
better you know I did shoot up to about
ISO 1600 which can get a little messy
with the the gh4 but I didn't have to go
to ISO 3200 and then for some of the
interior car shots having a wider angle
field of view helped with the variety of
shots we could get we could get two
shots on characters and have them both
interacting within the same scene and as
far as lining up the shots you know that
also came down the lens selection for us
I own a couple of Nikon f-mount
photography lenses so that interior car
shot I was just referring to I used the
Tokina 1116 2.8 which for my money is a
pretty sharp lens and you know the
distortion wasn't too crazy and also the
the color and the contrast quality of it
it's fairly consistent with some of the
other lenses I was using which meant I
didn't have to do as much matching in
post-production the other lenses already
on is a telephoto Nikon 80 to 200 2.8
the AFD version it's an older version
and there's a there's a deer shot in the
movie not literally shooting the deer
but like filming the deer where you know
I can only be so close to this animal
before we get skittish so having that
particular lens was extremely helpful in
being able to capture that footage as
well as some additional telephoto shots
it was my my go-to telephoto and then
that cow that leaves kind of the
workhorse lenses that we use for the
majority of the picture so Sigma has
actually really stepped up their lens
game and they released an art series of
lenses which includes a lot of primes
which are fantastic for moviemaking but
we only had so much time to film so we
ended up renting a sigma 18 to 35 one
point
eight which for my money acts like you
know primes in that entire focal length
so from 18 to 35 millimeters at 1.8 the
sharpness wide open
the lack of chromatic aberration the
consistency of the contrast and the
colors and everything it just it
performed really well so having that
zoom lens on the front of the camera for
a lot of the shots and not having to
change lenses really save time between
setups so you know time time is is money
on a film set and when you only have so
many days to work with your talent not
having to switch lenses is kind of a big
deal we also did rent a sigma 51.4 art
lens and either one of these lenses
honestly you know if you're looking to
use them for production in general
they're not crazy expensive but they're
very affordable as a rental and the 51.4
we're able to use for some tighter
close-ups to really knock the background
out of focus also in some low-light
situations where we needed that extra
two-thirds of a stop of light you know
it did come in handy so it was
definitely worth having although that 18
to 35 is what rode on the front of the
camera for the most of the filming how
does it all this add up to the look of
the production within the the world of
blood on the leaves we have the wood
scenes which is where the two main
characters interact throughout most of
the movie and even though the hunter is
at home in the woods he's being held at
gunpoint
he's interacting with somebody that he's
not sure he can trust city boy is
completely out of his element and he you
know has no idea how to really get out
of this situation and so there's there's
a lot of great areas to how the
characters feel about their situation
and also what kind of consequences their
decisions might have so to that effect I
did grade the footage a little bit lower
contrast for the wood scenes the colors
still pop because the characters this is
more production design thing but the
characters are wearing an orange vest
with an
orange camo cap for the hunter and city
boy is wearing a red hoodie so those
things really helped me to kind of
isolate the characters out of that
wooded wooded backdrop but as I said
with the the overall look of it you know
for the most part was lower contrast and
then I shot with that 18 to 35 1.8
fairly close to wide open so that the
backdrop was still present but you're
able to focus in on the performance of
the characters now for city boys world
the actual urban areas whether it was an
interior or an exterior we're going with
the choice or with the decision to make
it a little more contrast II you know in
his world it's all about survival you
know if you make this decision and
you're able to you know better your life
or get ahead of the game you know it's
very clear what is right right is
survival wrong is putting yourself into
a situation where you're you know you're
gonna end up dead so you know very
contrasting dark shadows
you know pools of darkness in certain
parts of scenes and things like that
there's nighttime scenes so you know
overall look it was really those two
worlds you know in the the way the
characters felt about their worlds that
motivated them and we were able to use
the v-log on the gh4 to allow us to make
those kinds of decisions in post so as I
said you know for our particular
production price file size battery life
dynamic range where some of the biggest
reasons we chose the Panasonic gh4 I
think you'll find that there are lots of
different fantastic cameras out there
that are gonna fit the kind of
production that you're working on and
there's lots of great resources if you
don't have the money to perhaps perhaps
rent these cameras beforehand
so go on and check out you know Philip
Bloom go out and check cinema 5d ye OS
HD new shooter these are all fantastic
sights lots of footage you know people
that have had lots of experience with
you know wide variety of formats
perhaps can give you you know a little
entry point for making some of those
decisions obviously you know you can
also check out the kind of content we're
releasing for blood on the leaves it's
at BO TL movie calm and if you want to
reach out to us directly with any kind
of questions or feedback you can reach
us at be oto movie at gmail.com
so thanks film courage and I look
forward to seeing some of your guys's
production behind the scenes up here as
well